melvin percebois est rentrée au lycée ce
mardi matin sa grève de la faim n'aura
finalement duré qu'une journée
le temps pour lui d'être invitée sur un
plateau de télévision et d'obtenir de
jean michel blanquer
le ministre de l'éducation nationale la
promesse d'une réponse sous 48 heures
c'est sur les réseaux sociaux que melvin
a lancé son action en publiant plusieurs
vidéos ces revendications passer le bac
sous la forme d'un contrôle continu
comme les bacs généraux et obtenir une
amélioration des conditions sanitaires
qui se dégradent selon lui en salle de
classe
j'ai eu l'idée de faire cette vidéo
quand j'ai vu dans dans l'état je
commençais à aller mais surtout dans les
cas dans l'état aussi ou où étaient mes
camarades de classe dans l'état de
stress de détresse même une détresse
après aussi tous les étudiants qui sur
les réseaux ont commencé à se manifester
ça parlait de phobie scolaire le prof
nous ont clairement dit que nous
pourrons pas terminé le programme
les sujets sont déjà fait ça je pense
qu'à une semaine deux semaines des
épreuves ils vont parfaire les sujets
donc je vais m'asseoir devant ma feuille
et je regardais le sujet a maintenant ça
je peux pas faire je n'ai pas vu en
cours ou sage n'est pas terminée donc je
vais être désavantagé aussi là dessus je
marque et quoi sur ma feuille désolé
madame ou des correcteurs j'ai pas pu
terminer sans cours je peux pas répondre
à ma question
dans sa démarche melvin est soutenue par
sa famille qui le voient comme
l'instigateur d'un combat collectif
lui ce qu'il voulait c'était faire
bouger les choses
donc on lui a dit bon bah si tu penses
que ça peut faire avancer la situation
vas-y quoi c'est pour le bien de tous
il est tout le monde sait il cède pas
que lui veut aider tous tous les lycéens
et tout
tous les étudiants en fait un soutien
que melvin retrouve également auprès de
ses camarades
ils louent son courage bah franchement
je pense que son combat il est très bien
je pense qu'ils aient abouti là
devraient des vrais débats d il est
courageux il est courageux et simplement
franchement j'ai trouvé déjà très
courageux dans un premier temps ensuite
tout ce qui fait franchement c'est bien
il faut juste pas aussi qu'il a lieu
jusqu'au bout de ces choses ne sont
combat et tout y est franchement
dangereux de les soutenir dans tout ce
qu'il va faire melvin attend désormais
une réponse claire de jean michel
blanquer r faute de quoi il appellera à
un blocus des lycées